president Trump you probably reading
about this continues to baffle both
Democrats and Republicans yeah no one
knows which Trump they're gonna get on a
certain day right it's crazy
here's the latest president Trump now
says he wants the wealthy to pay more
taxes and he wants undocumented minors
to be allowed to stay in the country
[Applause]
then this morning Trump accused himself
of being born in Kenya
that's how weird it's good he want I
want to see my birth certificate that's
what he said getting really weird Trump
supporters are angry you can imagine
right Trump supporters are outraged over
the president's recent reversals on
immigration Trump supporters are very
upset this is the first time they've
ever been this angry at a white male
veto that stop anyone how to process
back
but he's not changing all his habits
president Trump not changing all his
habits this is true President Trump was
very busy all night last night tweeting
about Hillary Clinton all night he was
up tweeting about Hillary Clinton yeah
as a result Melania Trump spent all this
morning thanking Hillary Clinton a good
night's sleep oh my god can you imagine
ah I'm coming to bed
[Laughter]
prepare yourself for the best yeah
I'll be there soon people are
legitimately disturbed yeah yeah I
apologize let's talk about other stuff
Huma Abedin and soon-to-be ex-husband
Anthony Weiner you know they're
splitting up they say they want to keep
their divorce proceedings private yeah
however Weiner insisted he's still going
to keep his penis public he wants that
out he says it paints it needs air Carly
Facebook is under fire because during
last year's elections Facebook sold lots
of ad space to Russia yeah yeah Facebook
said the problem has been fixed now
they're selling that ad space to a
really nice lady named Isis so pays her
bills on time
that guy's like oh yeah okay what else
is going on the US government has
announced a deal to sell 18 fighter jets
to Canada we sold it yeah yeah yeah yes
those jets will help Canada protect
itself from its most hated enemy bad
manners that's it's not Parliament here
I didn't think that was that good
they're allowed not to laugh they're
nice people you're nice people but
that's just you just to go like
technically he said something and then
he was doing severe
I prefer an awkward silence is what I'm
saying that's this that's the milieu I
enjoy security experts true story
security experts are now keeping a close
eye on the rise of Osama bin Laden's son
did you know that yeah even worse they
say Osama bin Laden jr. may be working
together with his siblings Eric bin
Laden and I've anka bin Laden
[Applause]
you